brace yourself bachelor nation because
love is dead
okay maybe not dead but Tyler Cameron
and Gigi Hadid are definitely dunzo a
source close to the situation tells ET
that the former Bachelorette contestant
is now single he and Gigi are no longer
dating now we first thought something
might be up when Tyler Bart ended on
watch what happens live on Tuesday and
said this are you thinking right now are
you single right now single ladies
[Applause]
that's quite different from what he told
ET exactly one week earlier are you in
love with a supermodel Tyler Cameron and
I at the point where I don't really want
to talk about my relationships I've
dated publicly yeah so I'm trying to you
know date probably and you know I mean
I'm gonna love anybody right now I'm in
love with myself being love with
yourself I guess yeah that's a good way
to put it we saw some very public photos
of you and Gigi Hadid yeah so where are
you guys at right now we're just friends
we're just friends Fisher yeah that's
just where we're at our relationship is
need to be public it's she's good she's
good people she's an amazing person and
we're just keeping it keeping it
friendly
she's an amazing person we've had great
time together yeah you nervous right now
yeah Tyler it's a weird thing you got to
talk about your love life you know
that's the bachelor that's this
franchise it's kind of crazy yeah so can
you tell us a little bit about how you
guys formed your relationship did you
meet through the modeling thing I don't
want to talk about our relationship but
you know we get it
summer ended so the summer fling had to
end too and Tyler and Gigi are both
gonna be fine she's off being a runway
superhero in France and he's living his
best life he just did a big spread for
GQ got his own apartment and just
overall seems genuinely excited for his
future I'm extremely happy you know
wife's life has changed for the better
it's great I mean I get to take my
little brother to Paris in a couple of
weeks like these are things that I never
would have gotten to do you know
like you know I told my dad the other
day like write 10 things down that you
always wanted to do and like I'll make
it happen
you know and it's just like I'm doing
I've been given opportunities that you
know and like a head start in life and
it's grateful and it's opened a lot of
doors for me and I want to just do good
by it and you know keep planning you
know keep doing things with the kids
that work with ABC Food Tours and and
all that and just trying to keep putting
positive Network now we just sit and
wait to see who these two crazy kids
date next stick with ET for all the love
life updates
I'm Katie Krauss and I'll see you next
time
[Music]